hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
um april 11th
2022
222 what's going on how are you
i'm gonna be recording this in sections
everybody because uh
yeah i'm out here in augusta georgia
hey wait what you doing all the way out
there freckles what you doing you
working on some moonshine
there's nothing like that out here
there's arby's
hooters
walmart cvs it's just you know
it's the same old same old
um but i am at the masters this weekend
and uh for first before i get to the uh
masters
masters masters
bam sorry there's no way to do that if
you grew up in the 80s no way not to do
that
the whole time i would i would be like
hey people who asked me what are you
doing this weekend i was going i would
be like i'm going to the masters and i'd
be masters masters i talk to anybody in
my age group like they just start
[ __ ] saying it
like a lab rat you can't you cannot say
it i don't know why they haven't asked
metallica if they oh i know why because
they're a golf course and they're
prestigious
um
anyway
before i get to that i played birmingham
alabama
alabama
and i played macon georgia and these
were my first three real shows since i
had my little billy soliloquy over the
last uh
six weeks and um i don't think they
could have gone any better
and um i was working with version
bartnik because we were all going out to
the masters
masters can't not do it um
and
i was saying
how i was gonna bring up how much i love
doing stand up in the south how much i
[ __ ] love
the crowds
i love being billy liberal from
hollywood
you know making fun of hollywood teasing
them about being southern and they
[ __ ] roll with it and there's some of
the best crowds like the
show in birmingham was awesome and then
we went to macon
and
we played that historic place which i
went in and it looked like
they hadn't changed anything they're
about to redo it and i got in there
right before they did and
i was like this looks like
the same wallpaper and
and everything from 50 years ago when
martin luther king's funeral was here
and they said yeah it probably is and
the stage was still you know from years
of people performing had like all these
scuff marks on and stuff and it was uh
gotta be honest he was a real like
i don't know just felt the
the presence of that history in there
and it was um
such a cool
venue
to be in and the crowds were [ __ ]
amazing i had so much fun in making
georgia the only thing that stunk was i
didn't have time to go to dwayne and
greg allman's um
graves grave site
um but i'm definitely coming back that
was one of those ones like i got 10
minutes
into the first show and i'm like there's
no [ __ ] way i'm not coming back here
and when we were in um
birmingham alabama
um
home of the university of alabama
birmingham blazers
we had a great time out there and i got
to give a shout out to everybody at
saw's barbecue
who opened up just a little bit early
for us um club soda kenny made the call
and uh they gave us a little vip tour
showed us their smoker and everything
and uh
i found out i actually like fried okra
who knew
and um
just absolutely delicious food it was so
great my favorite barbecue place in the
nation saw his barbecue smart ass
wilson's you got to check it out if
you're ever down there
and um oh billy freckles i got to tell
you the first night i did 49 minutes
that had nothing no jokes from my red
rock show
that special i don't know when it's
coming out but i i know i have to
um
i gotta have an hour and ten minutes
before that thing comes out and
on uh
the next night in macon
can you tell i'm excited i did like a
little more than 50 minutes and then by
the end it was like an hour so i feel
like i'm ready to go
and it was killing and i just picked up
right where i left off it was like the
movie never happened and i had so much
fun so thank you so much to everybody
that came out just truly truly awesome
awesome people um
coming out and uh once again if you're a
[ __ ] smart aleck yankee from the east
coast
and you're a comedian do not sleep on
the south man [ __ ] amazing fans down
here so with that
um
right after the show we had to run right
out
jump in the car and come up to augusta
so we could be there for the uh
day three of the masters
and um
i have to tell you it was so amazing to
come back but it was [ __ ]
freezing
it wasn't freezing it's just that you
know we all came there like we were
gonna watch golf
and thank god i had my little [ __ ]
puffy coat
um because other than that i just had
this don't get sunburned hat that i was
wearing in my [ __ ] bald head dude i
felt like i was at a football game in
october and i was dressed for baseball
that's what it was it wasn't that i mean
it was like 59 degrees probably
48 with the wind the wind was [ __ ]
nuts and everybody's sitting out there
with like [ __ ] windbreakers on and
[ __ ] shorts
just freezing our
[ __ ] balls off it was [ __ ]
miserable i don't know how those people
were golfing out there
but um
we came in and tiger was you know
practicing some chip shots got to watch
that
i watched uh bubba watson that's my guy
anybody wins the masters and then goes
out and buys a [ __ ] 69 dodge
challenger is all right with me
um
watched him play with uh
uh
oh [ __ ] what's his name i'm so bad
with [ __ ] names at my age
the [ __ ] did he go out with i already
forget um
no i know his name i just can't remember
it's just not gonna pop in because i'm
old
sergio
garcia
saw them tee off
and then uh saw another group tee off
and then i saw tiger tee off
i saw tiger make a birdie on two
and then me and verzi went over to our
spot which is we sit in the bleachers
um on 15 like we did in 2010
when we were betting on the turtles
which one was going to go next in the
pond and i was destroying versey
because versey kept betting on turtles
that had a wet shell and i was like
that's got the driest shell i would bet
on that one i was killing him
um
so we sat there and we just bet
every twosome that was coming over we
would just betting them
you know
most of the times you know it would just
be a push but it started off five bucks
around moved up to 10 and by the end it
was 50 and it was going to move on to
100 but by then tiger had already gone
through and we were going up uh
you know because we're coming back again
on sunday so i'm gonna watch the rest i
watched everyone from the bottom of the
field all the way up to
whoever came through right after tiger
and i missed all like
the leader leaders but i'll see them
tomorrow
probably going to go
i found out too you can [ __ ] smoke a
cigar in there i couldn't believe it i
saw these two guys with sticks i'm like
dude what the [ __ ] you can smoke in here
he goes that's exactly what we said
yesterday when we saw a guy with cigars
so you can't smoke in the bleachers but
you can kind of like walk around so i
think i'm going to uh
you know
i think i'm going to amen corner
tomorrow
and i'm going to bring like two sticks
and i'm just going to sit there and just
i'm going to watch all the leaders go
through and then uh go up to 18. dude
i'm telling you like
what's amazing about going to that
course is literally
like looking at like down the fairways
it's like seeing a celebrity if you've
been watching it for so long i remember
coming up over hill they're like i was
with club soda kenny he goes do you know
where you are because we're trying to
meet some of our other buddies you're
not allowed to bring a phone in there or
anything
um
he's like do you know where we are and i
just looked at this fairway i'm like
that's 18.
that i've seen that a million [ __ ]
times when people are about ready to win
it or [ __ ] choke it away just looking
right down that fairway and seeing that
halfway point that they get to with that
sand trap right there
um i got to see tiger play 18
and um
[Music]
and i got to see him play 15 16. i got
cmt off on one birdie on two 15 16 and
18. i made sure
that i saw the king
one more time because i know he's gotten
that horrible accident and you know
talking about amputating his leg and he
definitely was walking like he was in
pain uh but i i just had to see the guy
play one more time because that's you
know
the greatest golfer of all time in my
opinion
so anyway it was a [ __ ]
miserable day but it was still awesome
because it was the masters
and the [ __ ] lines
to go in to get all the merchandise
which i know they have [ __ ] online but
like they don't have all this other cool
stuff and i just saw the line
and i was like you know the last time i
was here
i bought a bunch of merch and i never
took it out of the box i still have it i
don't do anything with it
and i was just like you know what ah
[ __ ] it i'm not gonna buy anything and i
was seeing everybody with all their
masters [ __ ] [ __ ] on it
i was kind of feeling stupid like i
should have got something and then when
i walked out
without a bag of [ __ ]
i felt great
i really did
you know i'm not saying you shouldn't
buy some stuff if you're young go ahead
and buy this [ __ ] oh no actually if
you're young i'm telling you
that [ __ ] [ __ ] haunts you because
then for the rest of your life you're
gonna be looking at that thing that you
got at that thing that [ __ ] says the
year on it it becomes sentimental and
you can't get rid of it
you can't get rid of it and then you're
just
sentenced to lugging it around to every
[ __ ] place you live in for the rest
of your life or
you can just not
buy anything
and have a great time
you know and just have the memory
that you went there overrated
souvenirs
i'm i'm going to say it right now oh i'm
i'm oh i'm being dangerous look out for
me i'm out of
doing fred stallers i've said staller
zak here i'm out of control
um
yeah i just i'm the older i get like
what are you getting noth
nothing i'm i have the experience i have
the memory
it's [ __ ] awesome i don't need the
souvenir
i have the memory of it now if i get
older and i start losing my mind the
memorabilia is just gonna become
annoying like what is that i went to
that i don't remember
rather just having
a bunch of nothing i don't know
so
anyway um
we end up we have a blast and we're
gonna go there again tomorrow and um
it's been a really really good time
going with some comics and people
bringing their dads along and [ __ ] it's
just uh
really really uh a cool thing so i'll
tell you one of the best
one of the best as far as like going
back and forth this is when we were
betting 50 bucks
each it was funny we started off five
bucks each and at the end of all of the
[ __ ] going up to 10 going up to 20
because me and birds were just talking
[ __ ] right you want to do 50 because
he's like yeah you think i give a [ __ ]
i'll go 50. i'll go 50 around i go fine
there's 50 bucks
we just kept going back and forth and in
the end he owed me five bucks that was
it
um but we got 20 bucks each on red sox
yankees and they won last night so i'm
down 15 to the bastard so hopefully the
socks will win tonight and again on
sunday
um but anyway he went down to go get a
beer or something one of those long
lines
and sergio and bubba come up so i took
bubba right you gotta love a guy named
bubba that likes a dodge challenger
right so i'm [ __ ] i put 50 on him
we're on 15.
uh shot number two we couldn't see him t
off but we'd always see him take their
second shot shot number two version's
not there sergio goes in the water and
i'm up 55 bucks so i'm finally gonna be
up a c note on this [ __ ] kid right he
goes into the water
i'm like that's it he's out right bubba
goes into the trap but whatever he chips
out he two putts we're good because
sergio has to [ __ ] drop
sergio drops so that's three
and then he hits a [ __ ]
perfect shot other than going into the
hole where he sets him up self up for a
birdie
then bubba watson goes to head out of
the trap i don't know what he did he
didn't hit it right it goes up in the
air lands way short rolls down the hill
and goes in the [ __ ] water he ends up
bogeying the [ __ ]
bogey in the goddamn hole
oh the ebb and flow the back and forth
there
um i did miss the bruins
i know that they uh they beat tampa bay
i think in overtime as joe bartnick says
and the celtics keep rolling along um
i start editing the movie on wednesday
but i am back into society which is why
this podcast this week will be an hour
long of me babbling once again and i
want to thank all you guys for your
patience
um
over the last few weeks and i am really
really antsy
about you know getting into the uh
editing room i want to start that
process and i got a lot out of uh
you know watching quest
win
um
ms oscar there and talking about
you know not saying obviously i'm doing
a comedy so we all know comedies don't
get awards
um
i mean more like
watching somebody who'd never directed
before
and saying how he just walked around and
thought about
his film for like five months he just
lived with it and i just
got so much out of that going all right
that's what i got to do so i got to live
with this thing
for the whole summer like right into
september when i got to turn it in and
uh
i'm looking forward to it and everybody
has been telling me like don't worry
about the first the first time you see
all the rough footage
don't worry about it it's gonna look
like it's a mess do not freak out it
always looks like it it's gonna be a
mess you slowly start adding it you
tighten it up and then you get your
movie so
um
i remember the great mike price from the
simpsons co-creator of f is for family
he told me the same thing
the on the very first episode when we
were watching the animatic and my
[ __ ] jaw was on the ground
going like what the [ __ ] is this and he
goes don't worry it always the first cut
always looks [ __ ] horrible this
happens every episode of the simpsons
[ __ ] you know 25 years at that point
in on it this is how it always looks i
was just like all right
all right man i'll take your word for it
um
oh something we did we went in in
birmingham was we also did that hike up
to that
i don't know what the [ __ ] they called
the viking i don't know what it was but
on the way there we walked by this ford
dealership
and they had this black
two-door eight-foot bed
uh f-350
which i don't know the difference
between the 250 and the 350 can it tow a
little more or whatever
better suspension i have no idea
um but it was
it was only two we wheel drive but it
had the regular cab i swear to god if it
was four wheel drive
um i very least would have called my
wife going you know it's kind of what
i've been looking for like to get it
what are you gonna do with it you don't
want to fix anything
why can't i just drive around in it and
pretend i'm cool
that's the purpose of most vehicles
you know you buy a vehicle you always
got to get something that's a little
cooler than you really are it makes you
feel good when you drive
all right it's just a philosophy
um
but we ended up i went to this pancake
place
also that was on the way on the walk i
went there on the way back in uh
birmingham they had the pancakes were
[ __ ] outstanding what i liked was
every breakfast seemed to come with
pancakes they liked the original pancake
house
and i was like wait a minute is that
like
are they trying to say the international
house of pancakes
ripped them off or are they doing like a
mcdonald's mcdowell's like coming to
america thing
like when we shot on a location um
downtown l.a
there was this place called the big
store and the big
was written in capital letters and it
was the same blue as big five out here
which is a sporting good chain
and when you looked at it real quick you
thought it was the big five store and
there's no [ __ ] way they didn't do it
on purpose
um so i couldn't tell if they were doing
that but i will tell you this their
pancakes were better dare i say than
what they have at the international
house of pancakes
all right
once again more
controversy
more [ __ ] controversy um
all right so this is good
i knocked out 20 minutes of this [ __ ]
i'm gonna go [ __ ] hang out smoke a
stick i'm gonna have another couple two
at the [ __ ] masters tomorrow and then
i'm just gonna shut it down that's what
i do now
all right
i'm billy feaster famine
although today versi was calling me
billy shivers when i was at the [ __ ]
thing we just started cracking up
just loving the name um come on in
yo paul birzy i'm doing my [ __ ]
podcast on my phone a little bit of it
right now
no it's all right i was just talking
what what was the nickname you called me
today oh billy
billy chevis your little shakes got the
little shakes um i just turned the hot
tub in oh nice smoke a stick
yeah just a couple of straight guys
going to get in a hot tub and smoke a
cigar
little cocktails yeah there's nothing
going on here
is it yeah i like it yeah yeah you know
[ __ ] bartnik was going like hey who
turned the heat on last night it's like
i did
i weigh 170 pounds i'm not like you you
[ __ ] whale tell them about how we go
we we kept going from 10 to 20 then to
50. 10 20 50 and i told me you missed
the most exciting [ __ ] uh you got to
come on this for the final like half
hour tomorrow yeah dude you missed the
one with bubba dude tomorrow we gotta we
got to go 100 ahead somebody's got to
[ __ ] put a dent in somebody tomorrow
yeah like somebody's got to give
somebody 300 bucks that just has to
happen because this nickel and dime [ __ ]
is really annoying me because i'm trying
to talk about the drama bus betting and
at the end i only owe you owe me five
bucks but i'm down
15. no what are we doing with red sox
yankees i haven't looked at a score what
do you want to go per game 20 a game
come on paul
peep the fans are listening 50 again
come on paul they're listening i'll go
100 again we're going 100 a game all
right cool there you go i hope this
doesn't affect our friendship
oh billy shevers
oh paulie peanuts kept going to go down
to the food there
[Laughter]
uh yeah i was cold oh billy shivers i
get cold man and you know what for the
longest time i i used to pretend like i
didn't get cold because all these other
[ __ ] red-blooded people didn't get
cold at some point i had to realize that
i was a ginger and god didn't quite love
me as you know he didn't love me enough
to finish me you know he took me out of
the oven early he didn't give a [ __ ] he
didn't give me eyelashes or eyebrows and
uh you know
one of the other side effects of taking
me out of the oven a little early a
little premature there as i get cold all
right oh billy cheverus
oh billy shivers was live and in effect
on [ __ ] uh
the 15th hole there all right that's it
uh me and first are you gonna [ __ ] uh
we're gonna chat it up here after i read
some advertisements all right that's it
uh that's not that's it it's just uh
this is the end of the first [ __ ]
what would this be this that'd be
times three the first 33 of it shut up
bill okay all right let's do some reads
now let's do some reads what do we got
oh
look who it is
it's all indochito
um indochino from weddings to work
functions to weekends out on the town
it's always the right time to dress to
impress especially
in clothes that fit you perfectly
indochito
makes high quality custom fitted suit
shirts and casual wear all at a
surprisingly affordable price you can
customize everything from suits and
shirts to chinos and bomber jackets at
prices more affordable than you might
expect wow i thought it'd be a lot more
than that
um in nochino
offers completely custom fitted suit
shirts casual wears and more
surprisingly affordable places get a
wardrobe personalized to your style and
taste without spending a fortune every
piece is made to your exact measurements
and you can customize every detail
choose everything about your suit
including the fabric lapel monogram and
statement linings create a suit that
fits you and your style perfectly
there's always they're always adding new
pieces so you can stay on trend and in
style check out their latest spring and
summer collections the best part
indochino suits start from just 429 and
shirts from seven and nine dollars this
season dress to impress on every
occasion within dot chi know get fifty
dollars off any purchase of 3.99 or more
by using promo code bora indochino.com
that's 50 off a purchase of 3.99 or more
at i n d
o c h i n o dot com promo code
all right
and lastly but not leastly oh look who
it is oh no i got two more it's solo
stove
huh all you lonely people you want to
cook by yourself but your stove is so
big it reminds you you have no one else
to make breakfast for
introducing solo stove are you socially
awkward but love having eggs benedict by
yourself i'm kidding it's nothing like
that solo stove there's nothing quite
like the feeling of gathering around a
warm fire on a cool evening and a
smokeless fire pit from solo stove makes
your outdoor moments even more memorable
because instead of having to constantly
dodge campfire fumes you can sit back
relax talk some [ __ ] and actually enjoy
the fire you know why you guys about
sydney right now because of me
uh right now you can get a great deal on
a solo stove fire pit solo stove fire
pits are brilliantly engineered made
with premium grade 304 stainless steel
not 303 304 and a 360 degree airflow
system that maximizes efficiency while
minimizing smoke easy to light with a
few
bits of starter your fire is blazing in
minutes perfectly portable take solo
stove with you on camping trips and more
shop now and get up to 30 off fire pits
all month long that'd be hilarious if
you took it everywhere you went
um
get invited to a wedding you bring your
solo stove i'll sit in the back and use
promo code burr and ch at checkout to
get an extra 20 off plus a lifetime
warranty and free 30-day returns just go
to solo stove
s-o-l-o-s-t-o-v-e dot com and remember
you get twenty dollars off when you use
the promo code bur and lastly now lastly
but not leastly it's simply safe
all right what do u s news pc magazine
and popular science have in common
they're all magazines none of us would
buy
so
so you wouldn't know
that they all rank simply save home
security as the best home security of
2021 in fact u.s news just named simply
safe the best home security of 2022 as
well
they've already done they've already
wrapped it up and we still have another
what eight months
um simply say protect your whole home
around the clock every door window and
room it's backed by the best 24 7
professional monitoring system ready to
dispatch police firefighters or emts to
your home with a comprehensive set of
sensors and cameras including the all
new wireless outdoor security camera you
always know what's going on inside and
outside your home simply safe
is less than a dollar a day and you can
set it up
in around 30 minutes and it's always
simple to use there's never a long-term
contract you can even try it out for 60
days risk free to see if you like it if
you don't send it back for free of
charge simply safe protects over a
million homes in the united states alone
you can customize the perfect system to
your home in just a few minutes at
simply safe.com
go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus twenty percent off
with interactive monitoring simply go to
simplysafe.com
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e dot com slash burr
all right and with that
as mentioned
um i was going to go to the second day
of the masters here um
which i did i have to give a shout out
congratulations to scotty schaffler
uh the guy came out of nowhere started
winning tournaments in february and look
at him he's got a green jacket come
april just like that
you can turn it around rory mcilroy we
got i watched him eagle uh 13. i was
sitting right there in the fairway i had
a big blue hat on so my bald head
wouldn't distract him
and uh
i got to see all of them hit through i
got to see tiger
um
play 15 and 16
and i watched him walk up the fairway on
17.
um made sure to take that in it's not
too often you get to see the greatest
whoever did it
um
what else what else
i just heard when that who the hell was
the kid the poor kid from uh
was it australia
triple cameron smith was it him that
triple bogeyed on 12 i don't i can't
remember but i had such a great time
everybody had a good time and um
we finally able to right the wrongs when
that guy [ __ ] us out of the tickets
the passes those pieces of [ __ ]
um and i got to bring the same crew of
people that i went with tried to go with
nine years ago so
i'm glad that that's all behind us
it's [ __ ] i mean
we were the walking wounded today a
bunch of old people
all of us
having to sit down actually i was fine
i would say i'm the sprite
of me and all of my old friends
you should see how exhausted they are
just from sitting in the sun
sorry took a sloppy sip of that i
apologize i'm laying down here um
yeah i was teasing him i go look at you
guys you look he just got done playing
football bartnik is [ __ ] hilarious he
was literally stretching his back
bending over backwards over this railing
and these women were laughing at him and
within two seconds one of them's trying
to help him out giving him a back rub
only bartnik could get a [ __ ] backrub
from some random chick
at [ __ ] augusta
um
whatever we had we had an awesome
awesome day uh let's get into some of
your questions here
for the week trying to knock this out
before i
fly back late night tonight um
all right what do we got here
oh my goodness f1 in vegas
is this true i heard the rumors
i heard a rumor
they're gonna have an f1 race
in las vegas um
that'll be amazing write down the damn
strip
uh
hey billy two tracks are you excited
about f1 coming to vegas also
what would be the best and worst city to
hold in f1 race thanks for the last
laughs
the worst
philadelphia
within 19 one-way streets all going in
the same direction before another one
the most frustrating city i've ever
driven in i'd say runner-up would be
boston
any of those cities that like new york
city would be terrible
i guess they could go down the avenues
but the streets are just so it'd be
great if they went to new york they
could fix their [ __ ] roads for once
um
let me see what would be okay
the best and worst city to hold an f1
race well i definitely did the worst
ones
um
trying to think of a nice open downtown
that's a good one
i know la has that one down in long
beach they always figure out a way
detroit has a race
they always figure it out well you got
to go like people will want to go to the
city
and it's also like i bet chicago would
be a great one to have it go right down
michigan avenue i think chicago would be
great it's the middle of the country
race fans nobody has more than a four
hour flight everybody could get there
great food great people
michigan avenue so you know you go right
by the lake
sort of our monaco maybe
i don't know
that's a damn good question but now we
have two races here f1 is growing faster
in the united states i'm saying it now
than uh soccer and we will always call
it soccer
because that's who we are uh 70s
cartoons
yo billy baloo
look at that a reference to the jungle
book
all you gotta do is look for the bare
necessities the simple bear necessities
forget about your worries and your life
i mean i had to sing that song like
every night for a year and act the whole
thing out with my daughter when i put
her to bed
because you don't need
to leave the car when you pick a pair
with the big paw paw
do i need to leave clue scully thanks
baloo
you eat ants you better believe it and
you're gonna love the way they tickle
something like that um 70s cartoons i
just started showing my six-year-old
old cartoons
yeah i've been doing that with my
daughter she loves bugs bunny
uh ever told
everyone told me that my kid can tell
the difference
and hate the lo-fi [ __ ] but i think he
likes it better
uh all i'm saying is the kid never did
impressions of bubble gumpy guppies
whatever those are but now he's he's on
his dick dastardly several times a day
you've ever given your kids eel right
there fred and show them any hannah
barbera um yeah i told um
my daughter we'd play a game what's your
favorite
you know cause now she likes to talk at
the end of the day
um she's beyond me reading her books and
that stuff now she likes to talk
so um
she asked me about you know what's your
favorite dog because she wants a puppy
and i said when i was a kid i wanted to
get two bulldogs
name one butch and one chopper because
it was these i loved bulldogs there was
these two cartoon dogs
in the hanna-barbera one was named butch
um he might have been on tom and jerry
i get them all combined now and then
other was named chopper like the littler
one
and that's what i was gonna do i was
also gonna live in a purple house
and i was gonna go to notre dame and i
was gonna become a lawyer so a lot of my
dreams you know went a little off the
rails there
but uh
i've been thinking hard about getting a
bulldog my daughter doesn't want one she
wants a different kind of dog so now
she's now she's saying you get you get a
bulldog and she wants like a black dog
with brown paws
and i'm like you mean like a rottweiler
a doberman so i've been trying to figure
out what exactly she wants but she's
kind of
she's going into those dogs where you
really got to keep an eye on them
that breed a dog you know like dobermans
even when they have their ears down
that's not true josh adam meyers
doberman always looks happy but those
dogs in general you know
german shepherds just have that secret
service look on their face the whole
[ __ ] time
um
made in
america made in america hey billy
waxhead come on man keep it nice man
um
hey billy waxhead all right
on the 329 22 podcast you mentioned to
write
in if we work for at a company that
makes a product in the us
hey
well i'm a sourcing manager at turtle
wax and i'm happy to say 100 of our
products
uh and bottled
and filled in the midwest
look at that while the heavy majority of
our raw materials are also sourced from
within the u.s
i could maybe send you some product if
you wanted to try it out on your f-100
look at that if you're going to wax your
car people
use turtle wax
by the way
shout out to the ukraine
the world had you as underdogs or maybe
propaganda did they didn't know what
they were dealing with
good for you guys i know i'm making i'm
talking about like it's a [ __ ] game
here but it's too depressing to talk
about it like what it actually is
um but that's
an amazing story all right everybody
should [ __ ] stay home including us
quit going around the world bugging
people all right you want their natural
resources pay for it like a gentleman
um american manufacturing hey bill i was
just listening to your podcast while
working i own and run a metal
fabrication company out of orlando
and i thought you might enjoy some
perspective on u.s manufacturing in
reality it is alive and well that's
great to hear i have virtually unlimited
work that comes across my desk and there
are at least 30 companies within the 30
mile radius from me that do the exact
same things as us and we are all slammed
as well
metal fabrication companies who knew
here in the us we just manufacture
complex and low-volume stuff that
doesn't make sense to produce with
low-skilled slash assembly-lined labor
in other words offshore where you don't
train people to save money
they're not low-skilled they're just not
trained um
there are thousands of small machine and
fabrication slash manufacturing
companies scattered across this country
with hardworking people
working non-stop to keep up with the
demand these job slash businessmen just
aren't sexy so they don't get glorified
by the media and or the education system
i mean this sounds like a show on
discovery to me in reality you know i
gotta prefab this [ __ ]
who's them a what's up for that goddamn
damn mixowitz um in reality
all you need to do is have a father and
son yelling at each other you get at
least eight seasons i mean you'd
probably end up destroying your
relationship
um in reality people would be astonished
to hear how profitable and stable they
actually are thanks for your podcast i
really enjoy it well that's awesome man
congratulations america manufacturing
people
metal fabric fabrication this guy's
doing so well he didn't even have to
give his [ __ ] company a shout out
um
all right overrated age
as a number
hey billy clockwork i'm an older
listener
one of your oldest for sure i'm 78 years
old in june
and you're listening to my podcast
that's amazing
you talked about getting older a few
times and how aging naturally is
underrated i agree though i do believe
in supplementing things
you're deficient in and of course doing
the work to find out what you're
deficient in yeah i should probably do
that i'm definitely on the back nine as
they say
uh but it's really funny when people
assume i don't know anything about the
internet or what's going on today the
fact that i know what a podcast is
and where to listen to it is something i
can't share with people my age i would
imagine i don't feel any different than
i did 20 years ago people
uh
people my age get sick and have ailments
and they start to throw in the towel
i don't get mad when people assume i
don't know [ __ ] i just feel bad for them
because they probably look at themselves
the way they look at me
uh when they reach my age oh they'll
probably look that way thanks for the
laughs look at that
some good life advice there
i hope i'm like that at that age jesus
christ
you can't you can't throw in the towel
you can't quit you just gotta [ __ ]
live
have a great [ __ ] time and uh when
it's time to go it's your time to go
that's it
sit there and mope around
you know because you're not young
anymore you were young
now it's over
quite acting like you got cheated
you know oh i could say some things in
my business
my business you know when people
complain about ageism
you know
i find mainly it's people who were
you know built their careers on being
beautiful and it's just like well you
know that there's an expiration on that
date
while you're young and beautiful start a
production company and when you get to
the age of being a mom and a dad play a
mom and a dad
you know
stop trying to make the world [ __ ]
sit there and look at you like you know
like you're still in your 20s you're not
is it ageism or are you are you
delusional
the amount of super famous people i see
complaining about that they have
millions of dollars it's like write a
[ __ ] script
get some people behind you
you know
the [ __ ]
when you were 20 25 and you everybody
said you were hot you were [ __ ]
making
people magazines 50 most beautiful
people did you give a [ __ ] about 35 year
old 40 year old women and you didn't
now you're that age and all of a sudden
everybody's gonna stop and care about
you that's not how it works
all right
that's it
i'm sorry you're as old as a mom go put
on a [ __ ] apron and play one in a
movie
if you're a [ __ ] you know
a guy you know put on a sport coat come
down the stairs with your pipe going now
now knock it off take those parts
stop getting mad young people because
they're they will they're [ __ ] young
and beautiful let them do those parts
your selfish [ __ ]
um
oh that's my hot take that's my hot take
on [ __ ] ageism um
anyway uh i once again i want to thank
everybody who came out to my shows this
week i am so [ __ ] over the moon about
uh
how well the shows went i can't wait i'm
gonna come back
gonna be haunting the [ __ ] comedy
clubs
to get the rest some of these ideas i
was playing around with over the last uh
three shows
and put it together and old billy
freckles is gonna be in the driver's
seat when my [ __ ] special comes out
man i'm gonna be ready
i'm gonna have a new hour and ten
minutes of [ __ ]
granted it's [ __ ] but i will mold that
[ __ ] to an acceptable level
that you guys won't be able to tell the
difference hopefully but now that i said
that someone'd be like oh i went there i
didn't think you were quite up to par i
didn't have a good time but
oh
go watch dungeons and dragons
go watch one of those [ __ ] shows
or watch one of those movies you know
with the misunderstood superhero
you know
oh i have eight pack abs but people
don't understand me
including my impossibly hot girlfriend
that's what they do know right
what are they why are they doing that i
used to like back in the day they always
had a dark side to them but you know
what i mean they had a beautiful woman
you know they didn't have to figure out
their feelings
all right they just defeated the bad guy
and then they won they went away that's
what they did
now since post therapy
all of these goddamn superheroes man
they all got to [ __ ] you know what
they're like they're like all those
seattle bands that came out in the early
90s that just sort of dumped their day
on you
you know i want a little more motley
crew
in my superheroes
or dare i say poison don't need nothing
but a good time now those guys were all
sad they were dealing with alcoholism
and [ __ ] diabetes and [ __ ] like that
they had all kinds of drama did they
bring that to the stage no they did not
they were like you know what these
people had a rough [ __ ] day
and then what happens all these seattle
bands gotta [ __ ] bring gloom and doom
because it rains nine out of ten days up
there and they just bring their weather
to everybody else
i'm a rock star but i'm wearing a
flannel shirt because i don't want to
get the sniffles because i live in
seattle
i'm sorry
i will never get over those bands
knocking all my hair metal bands
you know that's when i knew i was old
when those guys all came in
and i was like hey man like where's the
tap on solos man
you know
i don't want to nitpick but just to let
you know nobody in your band is wearing
leather man
um
ah what did i know
i was just an orange kid with a dream
um yeah the 80s were over when the 80s
ended that was it that was it for me but
ever since then i've felt like a [ __ ]
senior citizen i'm like the reverse of
the last guy that [ __ ] wrote in on
this podcast where he's 77 still running
around with his dick out you know me you
know i'm ready for a walker i'm not
gonna lie to you
uh no
i've kept myself in good shape you know
i do my squats oh billy squat face you
know
i do my sit-ups i do my obliques i try
to keep the core you know going i use
salad
i try to stay hydrated and uh other than
that if i could just learn to shut the
[ __ ] up every once in a while i think
i'd be doing pretty good
you know i told you i texted that to my
wife right
like a week ago i texted her i'm going
to shut up more
you know she loved it got a big heart
next to that text
you know it doesn't work the other way
if my wife said i'm going to shut up
more and i gave a big heart there i'm
like at that point i'm basically saying
get in the kitchen and make me a
sandwich which believe me that's what i
want to say
you know what i mean
can we make that deal ladies if if the
man in your life shuts up more can you
go to the kitchen more
you know sort of balance out you know
show that you're you're willing to kind
of step our way a little bit i mean it's
a [ __ ] sandwich
we're not asking for shiny [ __ ] for
christmas every once in a while
can you bring your precious ass out to
that [ __ ] kitchen with the island
that you just had to have
you know take out some lunch meat
all right there's a little bread box
over there right oh it's so adorable i
have to have it we'll open it up and get
the bread out of it now
okay you get a plate i'll walk you right
through it i'm going to walk women
through this because your generations
generations of women have stopped making
sandwiches
i'm going to describe how to make one
okay you take the two slices of bread
right you put them on the plate
you get out a condiment that means like
mustard
or mayonnaise
you know
hot sauce whatever the [ __ ] it is peanut
butter i don't know
not peanut butter whatever you get some
[ __ ] like you know the deal lunch
meat cheese pickles [ __ ] mustard okay
you cut it in half put some [ __ ]
chips on it
okay it's literally what
four minutes out of your day you can hit
pause on the tv make the [ __ ]
sandwich bring it to him
and when he says what did you do that
for
you just say because i want you to shut
the [ __ ] up for the rest of the day and
he'll laugh and he'll shut up and he'll
eat the sandwich and you can watch the
rest of your real housewife shows right
there
i mean how am i not hosting my own talk
show dr bill
how about that
dr bill
where i stress
no communication your communication
through gestures all right and then when
somebody does a nice gesture for you
then the other person has to just shut
the [ __ ] up for the rest of the day
rather than just saying hey honey i
swear to god
can you just close your [ __ ] pie hole
because that just leads to a fight
all right
and you know as a man or a woman or they
whatever you are
you know when you're annoying your
partner okay and that's the moment okay
you go down you get them the paper you
get them a breakfast sandwich you order
some croissants
some sort of food gesture
you know
you rub the head
and then that person should be like okay
they're acknowledging that they were
being annoying annoying and i appreciate
that and your reward now
is not only will we not fight about it
i am now going to shut the [ __ ] up for
the rest of the day that's it
i'll go for a walk just get out of the
house and leave the house for him why
don't why don't we try that
instead of talking things out
like all these other [ __ ] trained
professionals
you mentioned
um sit down just you know put it all out
there on the table
what so you can throw it my face a week
later
um
anyway it's baseball season it's formula
one season it's moto gp season nhl
playoffs are right around the corner
followed by the nba playoffs
covet is essentially over
right if you get covered now it doesn't
hurt you really
gives you a nice you know four days off
from work i'd love to come in
but i have the weakest strain
now
my throat was a little sore for five
minutes oh this is irresponsible
reporting
can't do this to people bill what are
you going to play doctor on the [ __ ]
internet well why not everybody else did
over the last couple of years
why can't i chime in why can't i put on
my [ __ ] lab coat
and start talking about [ __ ]
um
anyway we hung out last night
at the [ __ ] house
we rented before we went to the masters
and just sat around like telling stories
and [ __ ] watching jim florentine meet
the creep videos
you gotta see the one where he goes to
the restaurant
and he asks for pepper on his chicken
and he just [ __ ] no matter how much
the guy has he just
cheat more pepper more pepper the guy
went through three
of those pepper things
what did he call those those fancy
things
well they cracked the pepper he emptied
three of those before he turns the
chicken over it's [ __ ] amazing
that people just keep the ridiculousness
of that the fact that the person with
the peppermill that's what it's called a
peppermill at no point
was like
like buddy
i know the customer is always right but
go [ __ ] yourself this is ridiculous
we're ruining the meal
you know
they did they just kept cracking the
pepper
which i think is a metaphor for life
don't you
no matter what's happening
just keep cracking that pepper mill you
could literally run for public office on
that
people would get into it
and you play a fleetwood mac song
don't stop
thinking about tomorrow remember that
wasn't that the worst when bill clinton
became [ __ ] president you found out
he listened to yacht rock
i mean i guess it made sense he played
the [ __ ] saxophone right
saxophone has not been cool in a long
[ __ ] time i'm gonna say that it just
hasn't
last time saxophone got you laid
was the 1950s
you know when they were playing like
rock and roll
there any jazz musicians out there do
you have groupies
you know
do they come out do they have like those
[ __ ] black frame glasses
do like your girlfriend snap their
fingers when you say something instead
of clapping sorry
um anyway i don't know what the [ __ ] to
talk about i ran i thought i was gonna
have more to talk about but evidently i
don't maybe i have a little bit of
sunstroke
um
i will tell you one of the great
memories i will have
for the rest of my life was we sat on
the fairway at 13
sat right in the front row
and just watched the best of the best
just coming through
you know making a run for the title
and uh
we sat there for like an hour and a half
and just watched them all come through
and by the way you can smoke a cigar i
think i mentioned that in the first part
of this and uh i sat there
at augusta smoking a stick watching
these guys playing golf just crushing it
was amazing i actually had one point
um this guy's ball landed right near me
when i was trying to cross
i'm gonna say it was 15.
um oh it's a golfer's name he had a
tough day
he had a tough day where's a lot of
logos on his shirt
um
but he was right in front of me
and i got to watch him try to drive the
green just crush it
over these trees and then [ __ ] bend
it around to the left it was amazing i
don't know where it landed but it looked
it looked incredible
that's one of those things you watch it
you're just like you know because you
know you sit there you're like dude i
could do this
i could go play a few rounds i could i
could par one of these holes or whatever
and then you watch a professional golfer
come up and address the ball
um
and then do that
and then you just like oh that's right
that's right i don't think i could do
this i just never you know i never got
into golf because it just anything that
involves outside in the sun
that long it just i can't do it you know
what i mean
i was all right with baseball but you
know every three outs i could go sit
down you know
i could get hydrated
golf you just keep [ __ ] walking by
the way what is that douchey thing every
golfer does that
when you drive a golf cart you have to
have one leg hanging out
what is that about
i know i guess because you're getting in
and getting out but even if they drive
around there's just something about it
like you're just driving with your leg
hanging out yeah i'm a member here and
here are my nuts
look at me look how great my life is
going there's just something about it
you just want to see him sideswipe a
tree and watch the guy's leg get folded
back
you know
i don't know the old me i could have
really worked up a lot of anger about
that but now i just it's sort of a
middling
anger but back in the day
well i kind of just wish that the guy
would sideswipe a tree and [ __ ]
bend his leg back at the hip i mean i
guess that's
sort of an angry thought would you say
how's your guy's anger doing
i'm going to tell you man
i'm not advocating this but i'm going to
tell you two trips on mushrooms and i
feel a lot better
spread them out a year apart first time
i had a bad trip second time i had a
[ __ ] blast
i think i'm gonna do that for the rest
of my life just once a year or whatever
i'm gonna take some shrooms man
that's it i don't [ __ ] with the weed
i don't [ __ ] with the booze every once
in a while with the weed
you know
every once in a while i'm not gonna lie
to you when i rapped on the movie i came
home and i smoked a little bit
but that's it i don't have that [ __ ]
anymore man
or i gotta like
i don't think i don't think i have to do
that anymore
where i worry
when i became like this habit guy
i started doing it every night i kind of
got i don't know ever since post
mushrooms i'm like i don't want to be
doing that every night right and then
whatever that voice my head goes right
and then i just walk away from the [ __ ]
i never used to do that i used to be
like i don't want to drink tonight and
then i come home all right i'll just
have one
two
three
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten snoring next to my wife
did you drink again last night no yes
you did you're snoring i know that when
you drink you snore i could never get
away with it
you know
i tried hiding bottles behind the toilet
all of those tropes it just never helped
for me because the second i come in and
snore she knew what i was up to and that
was it
and that was it so
anyway
that's the podcast everyone i hope you
enjoyed it um i want to thank
everybody in uh birmingham alabama
macon georgia in augusta georgia
um
everybody i met was just really really
nice on this whole trip it was just a
really great way
to come back out on tour and i cannot
[ __ ] wait i have my biggest tour
of my career career career coming up
this year
and um
i plan on enjoying every second of it so
if you're coming out to see me old
freckles gonna be slinging his [ __ ]
jokes in a [ __ ] venue near you all
right go to billboard.com to check it
out that's it that's the monday morning
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll
check in on you
on thursday